to lay the imaging of the centrioles we
were able to identify the Microsoft
holes as the oldest and the microfossils
we discovered are about 300 million
years older than the previously thought
oldest micro fossils so they are within
a few hundred million years from over
the next the accretion of the solar
system and the planet Earth on the Sun
and the moon and so on I went to this
new wagon took super cross closed down
in northern Quebec on the shoreline goes
to the messed up of the island when I
saw these structures in the field I said
I have to sample this the most exciting
thing about this discovery is that we
know that life managed to get a grip and
start on earth with such an early time
in Earth's evolution which gives us
exciting questions as to whether we are
alone in solar system or in the universe
I'm keying to look at more examples of
hydrothermal vents deposits and if we
can take our knowledge of how organic
matter and microfossils are preserved on
earth and apply them to hydrothermal
systems and other planets like Mars or
Europa
[Music]